The first step in this process of adding context is to create a map.
D3 has some of the best geo capabilities out there,
and there is one area where it really shines.
Well you can create charts using other libraries.
We would be hard pressed to find another tool that
makes creating data-driven maps, as powerful and fun.
We will start simply, and build up,
by applying knowledge we've already learned, to create our interactive map.
The first step of which, is to simply acquire data, to draw map, which we
can then plot the data we already have, the attendance data for the World Cup.
Historically, working with maps has been a bit cumbersome since the files you
need to work with, are usually large complicated data formats,
such as Shapefiles, or other proprietary formats.
The reason being,
that Shapefiles typically encode a lot of data when you think about it.
If we wanted to draw a map of all the countries of the world, we would need
exact boundaries of every country, as a series of paths or coordinates.
A few other formats have emerged, somewhat hand in hand with d3.
Two of which are very related.
GeoJSON and TopoJSON.
When working with web technologies,
JSON can be thought of something as the lingual franca, and
acts as a common interface between libraries, languages and technologies.
Almost every programming language and
environment, has facilities, to work with native JSON, in some form or another.
And especially when working with d3 in JavaScript,
JSON's the most natural format.
So, when working with maps in d3, it seems only natural to
use a JSON based format to encode the coordinates you need to display.
And that's exactly what GeoJSON is.
One issue with Shapefiles is that they encode their
information in a binary format, which isn't readable by a human,
unless you use a special program to interpret the shape file.
GeoJSON on the other hand, encodes very similar coordinate information,
using valid JSON, with some minor extensions.
And it results in much more interpretable, and human readable, and
inspectible data.
One very nice feature of GeoJSON, is that it's very easy to explore and
debug using many of the common development tools,
such as simple text editors, or even in the browser console.
One of the issues with GeoJSON however, is that to achieve these features of
being valid JSON and human readable, the data file itself is often a bit
more verbose and substantially larger than a binary Shapefile.
And since often when building maps on the web,
we need to send this information with any web request.
For our graphic, it can put a strain on both our server and
the browser, and increase loading latency.
And one of the final issues I want to go over with Shapefiles,
is they can have some storage limitations, in the number of
properties you can attach to given shapes, such as names or other data.
And Shapefiles are limited in their maximum file size,
limiting how precise the coordinates in the shape of the map can actually be.
The third data format that we didn't cover,
TopoJSON, is an extension to GeoJSON.
It's actually much smaller than both GeoJSON, and Shapefiles in raw file size,
but also encodes topology, hence the name TopoJSON.
Which Shapefiles and GeoJSON, unfortunately, cannot do.
For the sake of simplicity, and since we won't be
using a whole lot of topological information in this lesson and
class, we'll be using GeoJSON, which in many cases, is good enough.